now to another mom
JLo yesterday she was back to work robed
up while heading into the subway and
wearing fur on the streets
struttin into a convertible Fiat Abarth
Jada was shooting a new music video for
her song amor amor amor and is giving us
a Jenny from the block vibes at 48 Tula
Lopez shows knit reflections 33 again
and those gold hoop earrings take us
back the Bronx Queens shot for 13 hours
all over Soho and served up some pricey
fashion
and you couldn't miss her in this
$22,000 black and white hooded fur coat
at night she paired these black leather
boxing shorts with a pair of nearly
$1,500 black booties closing down the
Bowery subway stop she rocked these
shades of blue including some navy blue
or a lace-up thigh-high it was all so
take your daughter to work day
we're told nine-year-old a me it was on
hand dad Mark Anthony is executive
producing J Lo's upcoming Spanish album
honestly to have him work on the album
with me was a you know scary because I
thought you know we're gonna fight it
was a fight we didn't really it actually
made our relationship even better
because we had a lot of fun together
remembered like where we used to have
fun
has Alex heard the news he has he loves
it